ايضا هذه هي باخ مو اذا مشاهدينا القوات
الروسيه اذا مع قوات هي تحاول محاصره
مدينه تباخمت من كل الجهه الشماليه وكذلك
الشرقيه وكذلك الجنوبيه بقيت فقط هذه
المنطقه في الجهه الغربيه التي ما تزال
مستعصيه بسبب استماته الدفاع الاوكراني
هناك كون تلك الجهه تشمل خط الامداد
باتجاه هذه المنطقه منطقه شيزوفيار التي
تقوم بها القوات الاوكرانيه بالحصول على
الامداد العسكري لذلك مجموعه فاجنر تحاول
قطع طريق الامداد هذا الى شا هذا اذا ماذا
يحصل خارج لندخل الى باخمه نفسها لدينا
بدلا مثلا في الشمال الغربيه لباخمت توجد
قوات فاجنر التي تحاول الاستيلاء على بلده
بلده خرمادا هنا تحاول السيطره عليها
وما زالت القوات الاوكرانيه تقاوم فيها
وترفض التخلي عنها وكذلك لدينا بلده
كرسنايا هنا في الجنوب وهي قريبه من هذا
الخط من هذا الطريق السريع الذي يؤدي الى
مدينه الذي ذكرنا بان القوات الاوكرانيه
تقوم بالحصول على الامداد منها مدينه
في المنطقه الجنوبيه من مدينه باخمت لدينا
هذا الحي حي حي
داخل المدينه حيث يدور هناك قتال شوارع في
المنطقه هذه هناك قتال شوارع ما بين
القوات الاوكرانيه كما ذكرنا وكذلك القوات
الروسيه اما في الشمال لدينا حي زارشنايا
هذا الحي في العمق في مدينه باخمه تقدمت
فيها قوات فاجنر وسط قتال عنيف هناك ايضا
ومقاومه اوكرانيه ولكن تمكنت القوات قوات
فاجنر من السيطره على بعض المباني اذا
هذا كان لدينا عن التطورات على هذه
الخارطه التفاعليه اذا في باخمه ماذا يحدث
بعد قليل اذا نتابع المزيد من هذه
التطورات على الارض مع مراسلينا من كل من
[موسيقى]
الان اصبح الامر اسهل بكثير من قبل فقد
تحولت قواتهم الرئيسيه الى باخ موت لكن في
بعض الاحيان يحاول العدو الاعتداء على
مواقعنا في مجموعات صغيره بالمدفعيه عده
مرات نحن نعرف اهدافنا مجموعات المشاه
وقاذفات القنابل العاليه وقذائف الهاون
طائراتنا المسيره تكشفها ونستخدم
الاحداثيات للتصويب واطلاق النار
[موسيقى]
معركه باخمه مشاهدينا في الشرق الاوكراني
تعتبر اطول معركه روسيه متواصله حتى الان
منذ بدايه الحرب وتكبد الجانبين فيها
الجانبان فيها تكبدوا خسائر فادحه صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز مشاهدينا كشفت اساسيات
الاستراتيجيه الاوكرانيه في ضخمه وقالت ان
مهمه القوات الاوكرانيه هي الحاق اكبر عدد
ممكن من الخسائر لروسيا لان كل متر من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه يكبد موسكو خسائر
عسكريه ماديه
وبشريه ايضا القوات الاوكرانيه تلجا ايضا
الى اطاله امد فتره المعارك لاضعاف القدره
القتاليه للقوات الروسيه بدرجه كبيره ولكن
هذه الاستراتيجيه يمكن ان تتغير وتنسحب
القوات الاوكرانيه من باخموت في حال طوقت
وتم اجبارها او طوقت وتم اجبارها على
المفاضله بين الاستسلام والموت هناك خطر
اكبر اكثر الحاحا هو ان روسيا ستجعل من
المستحيل مواصله ارسال الامدادات
للمقاتلين الاوكرانيين في باخموت وحولها
تقول الصحيفه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]